this week we've got penis payback rib
lovers and moving forward like a
relationship gone really bad
what does penis pay back moving forward
I got a dick to read lovers like the
guy's dick so Biggles all the way to
your ribs
I'll thinking Mikkel they're all dicks
you're just thinking about this all day
long
you need to get some immediately today
with Jess how do you want to hit your
ribs I don't I go it's too much idea it
all comes out the nice one more than
this this to hold someone what's in your
the wholesome one that's so cool
I love you for not knowing me the team
mom was a wholesome way you know you've
got like you you come across like you
used to be a chore like she might have
killed someone you know maybe because of
the hoodie in the hooves
yeah giving it away and the kids yes you
get a little Rosie Perez you know to me
sometimes when you win it's very
deceiving because she actually is the
host one
shoes I know I can't I can't hide my
chicken night
anyway so far first story the San
Francisco artist
he claims that Burger King stole his art
and the way that he does his art is that
they have like he does these tap and
hold games on Instagram
oh I picture he made a burger and he's
like they stole my art how does Burger
King and art they do commercials and
stuff so so Burger King's Instagram they
did something similar that he does which
is like this game we're like the face is
all jumbled you have to like hold it
like tap to hold it and like freeze it
and I'm like that's the face that you
create so this is Pablo or he goes by
Pablo oh my god what a cute picture that
doll
it's a really cute picture he knew that
he was kind of busted so he had to use
the little dog for girls to go shallow
with a giraffe on the shallow end of the
pool over there guys give a burn and be
like just kidding
crushed his soul the woods already to do
it be funny I'd go for it if I was
single it kind of looks like a nice
Amberg and I'd hit that that's cool
Annie Sandberg and screaming this is not
helping your cause she [ __ ] the dog
that's your line that was dead serious I
was super sick we know you don't know
how to joke Nikki like she doesn't want
the guy in the picture but she did sandy
buzz dog yeah dog is cute as fun
is he really thank you
really though so this is an Instagram
story that Burger King posted we're like
they're scrambling up the face you have
to like try to put the face together by
tapping a like stop it because you know
when you're watching Instagram stories
if you hold on to the screen it pauses
so what he did in order to get his
revenge is he tagged Burger King and
like this really elaborate penis photo
got him yeah got him have to do is go
like click hide photo right yeah I mean
they could easily get rid of it but a
whole day later though it was still left
up so he wrote on his caption at Burger
King recently stole my content for their
IG ads instead of taking legal action I
drew a big fat penis and tagged them so
it would show up on their tagged photos
page don't [ __ ] with me swipe for proof
not sure how long it will stay up so
everyone's like oh epic clap back so
like other people are also tagging
Burger King similar penis shaped photos
and they're following you with the
phrase justice for Pablo so that's a
thing oh my people are doing so they're
saying that the most he was saying that
well I felt that because they took an
idea that I worked hard to develop on my
own I gave myself permission to get back
at them in a creative way that really
wouldn't hurt them too much but would be
fun and entertaining for everyone the
most important takeaway that I want
people to get from this is that the best
revenge is creative so does he know for
sure that he's the only one that created
this type of technology because I've
seen that before so is it like he
invented all of that or other companies
are doing the same [ __ ] baby
also Instagram stories just took
snapchats ideas so like like you know
there's well that's what Instagram does
I suppose Facebook does they go yeah
they see something and they go hey we
want to buy that and when it people go
we don't want to sell they go wrong guy
we're just gonna do it
we were gonna give you money we're just
gonna do it ourselves but yes so they do
mention this article that he knows that
he doesn't own that concept but that the
face game is one of the things he's used
to establish his footing as a creative
okay so he's one of them he's like he's
a piece painting and someone else's
paintings like I paint yeah yeah you
know it's like a lot of people do the
same thing but he's like oh but but me
it's like that it just seems kind of
whiny you think Burger King was really
like any tag the melody maybe that's why
he didn't pursue legal action as you can
cuz he can't you really can't I really
can't pursue it I'm not gonna tell him
what I want to pursue legal action at
the big company right so but he doesn't
even know if Burger King saw his thing
and was like I want to steal that guy's
thing he they could have seen someone
else doing well instead of taking legal
action he decided to be a big story so
you know Reynolds rep talking about like
the hip hop style who's got a new like
YouTube channel or rapper
all Crooklyn well so would I say
aluminum foil you thought that was like
a rapper's name yeah I thought it's only
like oh is that a stripper or in that
stage aluminum foil I mean she had like
silver bronze yeah here we go
she's a smarty no matter what
it just goes right to sex I'll find a
way and then she's gonna dick it goes to
your ribs
oh well speaking of ribs so Reynolds
Wrap is looking for someone to travel
across the u.s. in search of the
tastiest ribs and they're also gonna be
handing out a $10,000 check to go with
it so their web show
for the next Reynolds Wrap chief
grilling officer so the cgo will be in
charge of posting photos of grilling
techniques and other multimedia on the
company's website and social media
channels that's easy just under four
ribs that's time that she'll send in for
this Oh have you guys ever seen you ever
watched that show how it was made yes so
do what about tin foil was great how
boring is your life was just thinking
I'm gonna wrote a lot so I'm like you
just watching tin foil like it means
sorry that I want to give good knowledge
in my head what they just smashed yeah
it's like it but it's a big machine if
it went like how the machine you know
it's like they melt it down then it's
like made into this big you know thing
that it's going and it's do you know why
one side is shiny and the other one is
it why I don't know I want to know I
don't remember all the details of this
you watch the show yeah why I mean did
you [ __ ] learn from that only cuz my
laptop died but yeah I mean seems like a
dream job for people who love to eat
ribs and travel in Java yeah yeah it
does see my future across the u.s. have
you traveled a lot in the u.s. I have to
have a lot bro shows things you know
I've been to a lot of them what's your
favorite state for ribs yeah yeah BBQ
cancer careful can you go this is Kansas
obviously Texas
okay now tell me the truth what's your
favorite state for rubes no Texas was
pretty good I would say whoever I've
been like because there's different
styles right there's like Memphis is a
guy they got good barbecue New Orleans
has good barbecue you know what Texas do
you like the sweet ribs or do you like
the pepper sweet ribs
I don't like dry rub I like some I like
it I like it dripping with sauce you
know what my dad does he puts that a
heavy layer of pepper on the bottom part
of the way and then the sweet sauce on
the top it's not sour it's heavy pepper
[Laughter]
sauce and we know I love that I've never
had a big rib oh it's good oh ever good
no it's not it okay okay now you see
lost all respect you have been taken by
good food and I like trash food that's
for that if you grew up on it it's
nostalgic though I grew up on yourself
who did man she has the same choice Wow
they just throw me under the bus just
portray it so it's not just portrayed
her voice thank you my phone be training
tanks yeah but guys you don't know she
you know and it wasn't my fault in the
ribs
leave Eric alone it's fine don't cancel
him I love what's his name
Joe Joe is great was a nice man you know
I'm saying it's not it's not his
father's what does he look like what
does he look like he's kind of might
like me wait do a doodler white thing
he's like for our last story Florida
will allow autonomous cars with no
safety drivers on public roads starting
July 1st it's about Florida Florida
nothing could go wrong in Florida cars
but did you say Florida to Florida being
a first and then no safety what what no
safety drivers so no human needs to like
be in the driver's seat I feel like a
car Jackie is about to take place we
wanna focus a ton of us guard the
accidents that have happened have
nothing to do with the cars they all
have to do for autonomous cars but then
you but [ __ ] goes wrong in Florida but I
want a little cabin I want to like I
want like think of how the cars are
gonna be different now you're not gonna
be like here yeah you're gonna be like
you're gonna have a cabin you're gonna
did you hear me I said I'm for it yes
not in Florida Florida needs to go last
yeah we need to figure out all they're
gonna ruin each other what is it before
Texas no they're gonna ruin it cause
people are gonna be like the only state
we've tested it in there were tons of
crashes and then none of us are gonna
get to have it because it happened in
Florida gonna do it in Vegas also
there's like okay okay yeah so they're
just gonna change uber like I don't know
what people are gonna do all these
people that made bad life choices what
you would do and you would rent it out
as
as the uber so you don't even have to be
in the car as the uber driver you just
send your car out to pick people up no
it's not you so that's not how it's
gonna work how do you know it's gonna
suck how it's gonna work
Hoover themselves over is just gonna
they're supplying they're gonna supply
the car it's gonna be just do it now you
won't have to yeah you don't have to pay
the drivers the drivers won't be making
any profit it's just gonna be so you
think it's less expensive for them to
have the car that is then who's gonna
clean the throw up and all that [ __ ]
well the cars have it go back to the
yeah all you're gonna have to have is
like a mechanic shop a cleaning crew at
the end of the day that's all you that's
all you're gonna need so bird drivers
have to just switch careers to cleaning
crews the robots could take over even
worse and you know that that public
toilet down downtown I like it closes
the door and just sprays OH
like what if they just clean everything
inside the car that's a tight braid down
he needed that I mean in the bathtub
[ __ ] in her bathtub so this new law it's
intended to attract self-driving vehicle
makers to Florida to make it competitive
with Arizona California and Nevada which
has autonomous test fleets that Florida
would like to compete with so there are
five levels two autonomous like
self-driving cars they're describing
that only level four and level five
would be able to be on the road which
don't so differences they don't exist
yet like outside of just testing
programs so I'll tell you each level
Tesla's pretty much drive themselves now
yeah nation
level zero is was like a 1968 Ford
exactly oh automation no power steering
no power see seven Porsche 911 and so
they're saying that that's just like the
regular cars that we already know it's
level zero level one is driver
assistance so that's the one we're under
strain conditions the car controls
either the steering or the vehicle speed
but not both simultaneously my Genesis
has that
of cruise control which also most cars
have adaptive cruise control most modern
cars most now yes and so a level 2 is
partial automation so this is when the
car can steer accelerate and brake in
certain circumstances that's all right
yeah no no I had no the lot of cars now
like like you you put like amount of
space you want to be for the car in
front yeah right and then your car will
brake in like but this one is also
steering so now is the Tesla autopilot
that so Tesla autopilot is level 2 and
so they're saying that tactical
maneuvers such as responding to traffic
sent signals or changing lanes largely
fall on the driver and you also need to
be scanning for hazards so yeah whenever
I put my autopilot to like I can't just
completely let it go I still need to be
like cautious because sometimes when the
lanes merge the Tesla like it doesn't
really register that they're two lanes
merging Thunder I see so have to brake
URLs is gonna hit a car zone like you
can't fully let go
so level three it's conditional
automation and so they're saying that in
in the right conditions the driver can
manage most aspects of driving including
monitoring the environment and the
system prompts the driver to intervene
when it encounters a scenario that I
can't navigate so the driver must be
available to take over at any time which
level so you can't sleep
yeah hey which level can you nap in so
then we're gonna watch TV level three
the example is Audie trap the ADI
traffic jam pilots that's the one that's
level 3 that is on the market that's the
only one that's that I already took it
took effect the pilot is better than the
Tesla
yeah it is Wow oh damn in this for this
cube for this yeah and it's a level 4 is
high automation so the car can operate
without human input or oversight but
only under select conditions defined by
factors such as road type or geographic
area and so they're saying that in a
shared car restricted to a defined area
there may not be any but in a privately
owned level for car the driver might
manage all driving duties on surface
streets then become a passenger as the
car enters a highway that's Cadillac
they're saying that the example is now
is the it's Google's now-defunct Firefly
pod car.prototype which hadn't neither
petals nor steering wheel and it will
walk into a top speed of 25 miles per
hour so Lord level 4 level 4 in level 5
they don't like no it's not out on the
road like it's only testing but they
want to just put them on the road in
Florida I have questions about this like
will they be able to be on the road with
people that are driving like that are
manning their cars cuz that's a problem
I think they know they read the other
cars like you're in her car like yeah
yeah like if someone starts slowing down
it starts slowing down like it reads
with the other cars yeah yeah that's the
whole life the whole point of it but not
perfect but even but even my car has a
even my car has like a lane assist and
all that yeah yeah I get a little you
know but like if a drunk driver hit a
non piloted car and then the guy was
like and then they did like a
hit-and-run or something like it was
that guy's fault or whatever no but I
see but it has cameras okay everything's
being recorded okay and then my other
question was what if someone hacked all
the cars and then they just caused
ultimate chaos because it's all
automated by computers they show the
cars new they can hack your car now but
I'm driving it so at least I feel like
oh I wonder if you'll be able to control
the car with the phone I'd be kind of
dope yeah just like go pick me up some
McDonald's yeah they've already done
assassinations in other countries on
like world leaders where so if you have
like OnStar any basic form of
communication between the car and the
manufacturer they've already done things
where they faked car crash you saw that
in a movie no no this is like serious
[ __ ] yeah like through CIA type people
and they've already done it there's
already fascinated with all that guy
just ran off the side of the road that's
why there's always conspiracy theories
about like people getting suicided and
stuff yeah because it will happen in a
car crash and it's like their car got
hacked yeah yeah yeah it's nice yeah so
I didn't get to level five yet but level
five is just fully full automation yeah
yeah which is not an excellently
driverless car so the example that they
use it says
yet but way mo formally Google's
driverless car project is now using a
fleet of 600 chrysler pacifica hybrids
to develop is level 5 tech for
production this way we have passengers
just yeah just a bunch of cars driving a
lot saying that it's only for
self-driving vehicles that are equipped
with an automated driving system
designed to function without a human
operator at all
so that's what that Florida lies for is
to attract people to come and
manufacture there so that's why we say
those kind of cars are gonna be like
you're not gonna be facing you know it's
gonna be their cabins I've seen that
seen like at the car show yeah nobody
know but at the car show they have the
concept cars yeah these concept cars are
their cabin so it's like a limo yeah
yeah and then there was like maybe we
could add bars to it because like maybe
you could drink and drive now because
then you're not driving yeah they're
saying that this law it would exclude
people from not being able to use their
phone so like you can use your phone in
these in these uh which level this have
to be number four and five for five
so three you can't use your phone still
no so no one basically has it and it's
kind of applying to nobody and nothing
right now pretty much but it's take you
just to be clear I have like this dreams
and injustice go oh my thank you
[Music]